[Music]
what's going on guys it is the most
spookiest time of the year
oh yeah happy almost Halloween today
we're gonna break down some horror films
that are so bad it's scary and the
movies are fun because of that we love
them because of that so let's meet our
distinguished panel of horror movie
fanatics first up you can find her on
Dark 5 on Amazon and she's one of the
co-hosts of best of the rest on
colliders Pro Wrestling sheet welcome to
the show Rachel Evans hello our next
guest he is the four exec ed etre at IGN
and he's the co-host of the we enjoy
wrestling podcast welcome Eric Goldman
thanks very much I think at some point
we need to talk about the crossover
between horror and wrestling fandom
because clearly there's a lot of it yes
Eric thanks for being here and this is a
friend of the family you know
she is the head muckety-muck the
editor-in-chief of screen junkies news
Roth Cornett the breaker is
[Applause]
distinguished as you indicated so our
panel has come in with a list of
overlooked under look for gotten films
that maybe people dismissed as bad but
they're so bad they're kind of awesome
so let's talk about them right now Roth
what do you got first up so this one is
I think to me the pinnacle of so bad
it's good horror movies like this this
this is the standard and if you you need
to see it just in order to know what
you're looking for yes missus pieces and
it's from 1982 it's directed by Juan P
kara Simone and it's about a killer who
is chopping up coeds in order to put
together a human jigsaw puzzle yes yes
and it is crazy over-the-top dialogue
nothing makes sense and the best part is
at the very end of the movie there's a
twist which features a castration today
nothing to do with anything it's not
nothing to do with the jigsaw that's all
nothing to do with the murder yeah it
seems like one common theme they keep
coming back to in these movies is like
some sort of psycho sexual trauma yeah
yeah yeah like throughout like across
the horror genre like there's just from
like anything from like Hellraiser
through the Friday 13th through because
I think some because of some of the
early true classics established that
psycho and so it's like all these movies
that were basically mimicking those yeah
we're doing it but maybe not well true
horror is usually sexual somatic so it's
usually either has to do with your mom
which is inherently sexual or just
straight-up like my dick doesn't work
[Laughter]
this is a to pieces Eric what's a horror
film that is so bad it's good I'm gonna
go I guess in some ways with an obvious
choice a movie that's so bad that it has
a documentary about it called best worst
movie uh-huh I go with troll 2 yes it's
just an amazing experience to watch
troll 2 this is a horror movie
I think circa 89 circa 1990 that was
made by Italian filmmakers but made in
Utah with an almost entirely
non-professional acting cast it shows
let me give you some advice I believe
the filmmakers could barely speak
English
this was their movie they were doing
that was about goblins movies called
troll 2 but that's just because they had
the rights to the movie troll
there's no trolls in the movie well what
are they so it is in the same movie
where a family goes to this small town
for some strange
Hovick
change program that they're doing with
another family and when they go there
everyone in towns weird things are
strange it's just a an incredibly funny
movie the acting is so stilted and funny
I'm not going to eat me
[Music]
and if you watch the movie that you can
watch documentary right after and it's a
great double feature cool around a
Rachel Rachel what's one of your
favorites so bad it's good horror movies
this might be another obvious one but it
is one of my favorite movies of all time
probably top seven
Texas Chainsaw Massacre to Dennis Hopper
yes please lefty who's lieutenant and
his whole family was Texas Chainsaw
Massacre yes so it's fronted by stretch
which is a very cool girl and she is a
disc jockey in Texas and here's why I
love this movie we see Leatherface in
love he is smitten by stretch and he
will do anything for her and his family
is chasing after her trying to murder
her and he's protecting her the entire
time which is the reason people hate it
it's interesting because it doesn't it
feels like it's in a completely
different universe from from the first
one I actually to a screening of 1 2 & 3
recently and the total shift of watching
that first Grimm movie that feels very
dirty and like you're there news 2 is
incredibly jarring yeah alright thank
you Rachel
getting us excited
background a Roth what's what's
something you know really feeling
because it's always the second one it's
slumber party massacre - I don't know if
you guys are familiar with the driller
killer but let me introduce you to him
for the fun part this was produced by
Roger Corman I should stop talking there
but I won't yeah mic job yeah might drop
right there this was directed by Debra
Brock this franchise was all directed by
women yeah um this is a classic horror
comedy where I I like this one too I
think I'm skating the edge a little bit
era because I think it's actually a good
movie because I think she's achieving
what she meant to it sure you're
watching you'd be like you think that's
a good movie I do he is a rockabilly
Elvis impersonator with guitar with a
drill at the end who sings his way
through murder
and also quotes famous rock songs like I
can't get no satisfaction amazing there
is a death by pimple in this movie my
pimple oh my god dermatologist horror
when it's really well done is that
roller coaster ride this is objectively
a ridiculous film bonkers banana pants
but he is truly one of my favorite
killers that no one loves I mean we were
left ready for a very good reason right
but like this guy is awesome awesome
Thank You Ross Eric what do you got for
us actually going to stick to the same
franchise that we were discussing
earlier with Texas Chainsaw Massacre of
the next generation which is the fourth
film and the exercise this is a movie
that I was made in 1994 then sat on the
shelf and was released in 97 now a big
thing happened in between which was that
they happened they lucked into something
which was there two stars went from
nobodies to very much somebodies which
was Matthew McConaughey and Rene
Zellweger started this movie made it
before they became stars was released
after and Matthew McConaughey by the way
he's having a ball you feel because he's
in this very low-budget bad movie but
he's going completely over the top a lot
of screaming in this movie my wife's
like can you turn that down because it
was like Matthew Akane keeps screaming
[Music]
thank you Eric Rachel please favor us
with one of your choices oh sure
how so a thousand Corpses a very
divisive film yeah
musician director Rob Zombie's there's
so much to hate about this movie and I
fully love that about it like I like the
grimy I like the gross
there's no storyline and there's no it's
so incoherent and it flashes back and
forth between it goes through flashback
and present-day but without telling you
when it was and without giving you a
timeline of what where the characters
are what state they're in where why are
they in a hotel room now why'd they
leave the compound I don't know I think
the thing that is the most upsetting to
most horror fans about house of 1000
corpses and it seems like a student film
with a ton of money behind it it's the
film that no studio wanted yeah I think
Rob Zombie doesn't get quite enough love
I think he gets dismissed a little bit
too easily because this is a just a
great cult gem back around to you come
on give us something give us something
cool okay so normally in the jaws
lexicon of films yes people will go
straight for a revenge which I get it
it's in the Bahamas it was personal it's
crazy um I say you're missing out and
I'm not looking at jaws 3d for a number
of reasons one ish aliy was meant to be
a spoof and a parody and like maybe they
should have just committed to that
because essentially that's what it
became this is a during a small boom of
3d yeah so the use of 3d is like super
amazingly cheesy there's like arms
flinging at the screen yeah and the
final showdown is happening between them
in the shark and he's coming at them in
the control room of this underwater park
it's a still frame of the shark like
it's not ranked so there's all of these
slow-mo shots of the Dennis Quaid and
Lou Gossett jr. going
[Laughter]
nothing make sense and it doesn't matter
does the catchphrase for so so bad it's
good movie that's great so Eric do you
have anything nonsensical that doesn't
really matter
- I'd love to hear - one of my what a
favorite movie of mine these days and
I've seen it as a kid probably too young
but a few years ago I washed again and
now I just love it so much sleepaway
camp yeah you know another post Sparta
the 13th summer camp slasher movie yes
but there's a whole lot going on here if
you haven't seen sleepy boy camp I will
say drop everything and watch it I also
say don't google it don't google it
don't look up what how it ends oh
there's some like sha Millan level yeah
don't watch it this movie is hysterical
from the beginning again strange
sexuality you know that is a running
theme here and I will say I have got to
give a shout out as it were to the how
did this get made podcast which I
listened to in general but they did an
episode on sleepaway camp that made me
go I have to watch this movie again
because they were so funny talking about
it and I've actually listened to their
episode about it many times because then
trying to logic what is the backstory
here what are we supposed to think
happen again a lot of this has to do
with the ending that I don't want to
talk about right but it's a it's just an
incredible experience sleepaway camp I
another one movie that I've made sure a
lot of people if they say they haven't
seen it I go oh come over we're watching
this movie
gotta stop thank you so much for that
Rachel what goodness you have for us
Jennifer's Body I agree I love that you
set this we come here tonight to
sacrifice the body Adam Brody he's in a
kind of failing indie rock band you know
how hard it is to make it isn't anything
in these days and so he decides to call
upon Satan to give him powers he just
has to sacrifice a virgin and so let's
pick the hottest girl at the party right
he's probably a virgin it's Megan Fox
Megan it felt like a movie that wanted
to have a message and they forgot to put
the message in - oh yeah like it felt
like there was a like commentary that
needed to be had and nothing ever came
of it I felt like I feel like everyone
in that movie knew what they were doing
yeah I mean you may not like it a lot of
people don't which I get yeah I totally
got karna what I got opened it was and I
think people really came to appreciate
it more afterwards so I mean it's got
like fifty percent on Rotten Tomatoes
this is not a well reviewed movie move
it I really loved how could I ever be
insecure I was a snowflake Queen yeah
two years ago when you were socially
relevant I am still socially relevant
and when you didn't need laxatives a
skinny an amazing movie given us such a
great list of horror films like if you
don't have if you're not planning like a
pumpkin carving where you're just gonna
have one movie after another just a
marathon I don't know how you're living
your lives are there any honorable
mentions that you guys do we didn't have
time to really break down but movies
that just need a mention as so bad oh
yeah they're actually kind of good
I guess I'll throw in Halloween the
curse of Michael Myers
Michael Myers is evil
evil no Michael Myers is evil because
there's a druid cult that control them
it's just and Paul runs it and Paul Rudd
makes everything better
well shout out Maximum Overdrive just a
movie that Stephen King ever directed
and it's like car crazy cars and MOT
literal monster trucks you see D Emilio
Estevez and it's nuts and crazy and
makes no sense and at the end of it King
was like I was on so much cocaine yeah
anything cuz it's all like you need that
super dream in your life and make us how
you thought purses Gatorade featuring
Tiffany and Debbie Gibson saying their
lines from their songs to each other as
dialogue B Gibson the 80s pop star oh
yeah now is my karaoke song yes well
you're gonna hear those words with a
giant snake head that you're at it in oh
that's exactly what I did so many good
bad movies which of these good bad
movies are you most excited to watch or
rediscover and did we leave something
off the list is there something that's
so bad it's frickin awesome let us know
in the comments section below
we want to know also you dressing up for
Halloween tell us so what's going on
there or are you just gonna stay home
and watch movies which is cool too we
like movies and I like these guys
Rachel Evans Eric Goldman Roth Cornett
thank you so much for bringing so much
weird fun movie knowledge yeah like just
I got excited to listen you guys break
this stuff down thank you guys for
watching screen junkies we'll see you
next time bye bye
[Music]